cops are always the first on everything
because firemen are at this station
playing video games you know yeah utter
having hot dogs hell yeah dude I went I
used to date a fireman's daughter you
they'd invite me anything they were
doing all they were doing hot dogs best
job ever every time dude they're like
you wanna we're doing this big event I
get to the event every time it was 11
dudes sitting down eating hot dogs
having a good time playing games
watching best job the the one thing cops
and firemen have in common is they all
wanted we all want to be firemen man
really oh hell yeah dude if I can go
back in time best job in the world yeah
I got nothing but admiration for him
dude and the world the world loves them
the world loves firemen dude you know
they ain't holding nobody accountable
and everything's a science too for
firemen they
I've got firemen are gonna hate me they
do see all the tragedy and death which
is brutal and I I feel for them in that
but the other side of it is is that
everybody loves them yeah because all
they're doing is saving and helping and
everything that they do essentially is
science you know I mean it's a fire if
it comes in contact with that we know
what's going to happen the wind's
blowing this way we know what's going to
happen it's all pretty predictable it's
not that thing it's there's aspects that
are dangerous but you know yeah you guys
it is a lot more uh
it's a lot more hypothesis like
hypothesizing in the moment going on yes
there's not like a lot of even house
fires if there's a house fire cops are
always the first ones on it dude I'd
shoot if I saw a cop a house for odd
damn shoot at it
that's who I'd be that way again man the
expectation is if you're a cop and you
get there and someone's screaming my
baby's inside my baby oh hell yeah go to
an award ceremony for the end of the
year at a police department there's
always at least one cop that went into a
burning building to to to to help
somebody wow because firemen takes a
while to get there yeah yeah well also
yeah it's like it's so hard to get a
group of guys to do anything together
especially yeah and that truck is so
hard to get through it's like get them a
little
you know I guess we have to have water
in it huh well the water's already there
yeah yeah well yeah they're I think
they're already full I don't know man
our relationships with cops and firemen
is kind of crazy when I was on graveyard
just because I was so jealous of the
life they lived and things I would call
them out for anything three o'clock in
the morning dude you're not feeling good
man you need to be seen by paramedic all
right let me hook this up and I would we
need paramedics just and they knew it
because we eventually become friends
because they're in the same station yeah
totally they would see me and be upset
but you know I love stopping by fire
stations man fire fire dudes have always
been cool and it's nice to get it to go
in there you know uh great job yeah it's
cool man especially in New Orleans like
we always love them because they also
are part of the parades so that's a big
thing in Louisiana is firemen get this
whole second they have this whole second
like
appreciation because the fire trucks are
in the parades a lot oh yeah so you see
a lot of that huh I was cheering and
waving flags does your child want to be
an officer [ __ ] no all right we made
that clear day one and my kid was little
we made that very clear with one
sentence you will [ __ ] never be a cop
oh damn so don't even think about it
don't dream about it don't anything it
will never [ __ ] happen what what
about a fireman ah [ __ ] yeah hell yeah
I'll do anything to get him as a fireman
yeah dude let's give him some Franks
right with the understanding that
there's going to be trauma but police
work man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one